how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and it looks like the
marvel cinematic universe really
is truly about to be blown wide open
i'm sure by now most people know that
spider-man 3 is looking to be
a huge multiverse movie with the
possibility of it starting the
spider-verse
or at least it being set up doctor
strange is confirmed to be in spider-man
3 and so is electro
jamie foxx's electro from the amazing
spider-man 2. and then of course you
have multiple reports stating that
andrew mcguire's spider-man and toby
mcguire spider-man are going to be in
the film as well
but filming for spider-man 3 is supposed
to be starting today so we should be
finding out a lot more about the film
very very soon including the title
but it seems like we may have actually
already discovered
what the title is and if this is the
true title which somebody from a pretty
big website is claiming that it is
it does in fact describe a multiverse so
let's talk about the title and what it
means but first be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all things relating
to the mcu and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win an
iron spider funko pop
so the reveal of the title is coming
from the twitter account ya boy ant-man
this person's name is frankie and he's a
writer for discussing
film a pretty big website that has been
right about a lot of reports in the past
and this person tweeted last night
spider-man
homeworlds remember where you heard it
first so according to this writer for
discussing films the name of spider-man
3 is going to be spider-man
homeworlds now based off of everything
that we've heard so far
about spider-man 3 this is kind of the
perfect title
if it is truly going to involve the
multiverse and multiple different
spider-man
in the film each coming from their own
home universe
this title fits what's going to happen
in the movie perfectly now of course
take this with a grain of salt it may
not be the official title although it
does surely sound legitimate but
apparently we're not going to have to
wait too much longer for tom holland to
actually reveal the official title
jimmy kimmel has actually been teasing
spider-man 3.
he even tweeted out a joke that he was
going to be playing the part of craven
the hunter
seemingly confirming that craven is
indeed going to be one of the bad guys
but of course he won't be playing craven
the hunter however it is speculated that
very very soon
jimmy kimmel will have a guest on a show
such as tom holland who will reveal the
official title
and all of this lines up really well
together filming is starting which means
the title is bound to get out pretty
soon
and apparently it already has since this
writer for discussing films has already
heard it so what better way to announce
the title before
it gets out than to just go on a big
television show and announce it to the
world
and this twitter account is also
claiming that it is going to be
announced on jimmy kimmel as well so
we're just going to have to wait and see
over the next few days
but if spider-man homeworld is the
official title
it does seem like that truly does
confirm the multiverse and
the appearance of tobey maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man as well and who knows maybe
even more like miles morales and
spider-gwen
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest details
about spider-man 3 and let me know what
you think about this title
spider-man homeworld in the comments
down below do you like it do you not
like it do you want the multiverse
to happen in spider-man 3 or not don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof